hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday so it's warriors
then livestream recap time like I do
every Thursday so basically we got a
couple bits of information just about
the Halloween event and a few other
things added so let's get started first
up there is a content bundle that's
going to be added soon and it's going to
be available for about a few days after
November 2nd we're so roughly November
5th
it contains every single event or every
single event item which is the mask
outfits the outfits you get from the
loot the effects the pulled the down
under effect the new wolfy mode that
came out today all that good [ __ ] for
just 30,000 steal now depending on how
many items you have it's going to
drastically decrease so for example
let's say I have every item except the
wolf emote my I won't pay 30,000 for it
I might pay like maybe 5k I don't know
it all depends like some math behind it
I don't know the math but either way
that's what's going to happen so if you
do want to grab that bundle and go right
ahead next up there's a new event order
called apollyon wrath basically what we
have to do is the community is kill as
many heroes as we can in the endless
march game-mode we do it we do when we
complete that mode we'll get 1,000 steal
with two scavenger crates now if you
guys noticed if you put for honor in the
past week there was a few typos on some
of the orders according to the devs
those weren't exactly typos those were
basically teasing about this new event
order it was kind of like spelling out
the name of apollyon but within the
teases so I didn't catch that I thought
it was a typo myself so a1 on the devs
right there that was [ __ ] crazy that
completely blew right past me so shout
out to them for that little sneaky
teaser and then next up is the content
of the week and as I said a couple
minutes ago it's the wolf emote I'm not
gonna show the video I'm just gonna play
it in the background it's too short to
just show it off it's basically the same
thing basically your character gets into
this little like bouncy type state and
then he screams and his all of his skin
turns into fur and it's really cool from
what I've been seeing is that if you if
you have the blizzard effect it actually
changes the fur to white which is kind
of nice so maybe depending on the effect
you have it might change the color
who knows I've only seen it with that
one but yeah that's going to be 10
thousands steal for each character or
you can get it in the bundle like I said
for 30k or whatever the price happens to
be for you next up was a little recap
that the Knights won season three of the
faction war if you didn't see that video
can click the card in the top right to
the little eye up at the top of there
you can see it and then you could be
taken in my video to see all the rewards
and what we got and all that good [ __ ]
if he didn't miss that so once again
check that out if you didn't miss it but
continuing on they had a little Q&A
session with all the devs and you
basically summarized it up the know the
faction war isn't rigged they've said
that multiple times the dev said that
they are investigating the post-match
freeze and black screen issues the best
way to help them is to send your you
play username to Ubisoft immediately
after experiencing these freezes so they
can review your logs so if if you're on
PC and you've had that happen to you
definitely head up the devs they'll
likely respond to you back next up is
all Feast of the Otherworld items are
gonna be permanent after unlocking them
but after the event ends on November 2nd
only the mask outfits will be available
to unlock you will not be able to get
any of the other items until presumably
next October
if this so called happens now two things
I noticed one if you if you are confused
let me sum it up throughout the entire
event you can get every single item the
downunder effect the wolf emo all that
good [ __ ] even even them and even the
mask outfits and the grasping outfits
that you get from the loot but after
this event is over you were only able to
get the mask outfits if you don't have
them if you don't have a certain loot
like say for example you don't have the
downunder effect for no bushi you can't
get it until the next event if you
already have it for one of those
characters you will permanently keep it
forever but anything that you don't have
you cannot get back unless you haven't
bought the mask outfits hopefully that
clears it up if you still have questions
just ask me in the comments and I'll
gladly repeat that and I noticed that
they said on so presumably next October
so there might be a little bit of a hint
that we might have a year 2 to 4 honor
which is great I've been loving this
game for the whole year and I'll gladly
keep reviewing this game for another
year and hopefully you guys will
definitely stick along for the next year
as well next up they're gonna consider
changing the ranked beta from a
tournament format to a more single match
format instead of the you know like it
said the original tournament mode that
we currently have it takes a lot of time
and it's very boring
just gonna make it one v1 you win the
match you go up a rank you lose the
match you go down a rank you up with
another person that's looking for a 1v1
and continue on your way they're gonna
they're also gonna be having plans for
the same thing but for for V for modes
instead of having a tournament style
it's gonna be a regular one match type
thing by obviously ranked for V for
isn't going to be coming out until
season four they're also looking in for
systems to promote the lesser played
game modes through rewards and are
currently looking at changing skirmish
to be a bit of a more interesting game
mode probably gonna be coming in the
patch of season four so hopefully
that'll work but also that's going to be
happening is that the Warriors then next
week or the next few will be all about
their plans for season four so do expect
some surprises once again I'll be
covering all that good stuff here
there's definitely tuned back in the
last couple of weeks there'll be
information and I'll keep you all posted
on that and then lastly to end it off
for the news according to the Deb's
season 4 launch we'll have and I quote a
big-ass patch so there's gonna be a lot
of bug fixes whether that be bug fixes
character fixes I'm not entirely sure
but is a big-ass patch so we're gonna
hat so there's gonna be a lot of info
and I'll definitely cover for you guys
like I always do and then end it you can
click off here if you want but there are
two really short things I wanted to add
if you do enjoy the move or these show
friends I know this is very awkward but
if you do enjoy the show friends someone
during the dev stream ended up making a
new intro for them with the friends type
of theme song opening so check the first
link in the description and you will be
taken to the video there also be a
timestamp - if you do want to see the
opening for that so I thought that was a
little bit enjoyable to watch and then
lastly I want to thank you all guys for
the love and support on my three most
recent videos these videos greatly
exceeded my expectation for the views
the videos would receive and according
to the social blade which is a website
that I use to get all my statistics or
my views and subs we've gained over 300
subs in just this past week alone which
is crazy so thank you all so the new
subs for joining and the old ones were
sticking around you guys the best like
the video if you guys didn't enjoy
subscribe for more for on our content if
you are new to this channel we do a lot
of leaks news discussions all that good
[ __ ] regarding for honor my two news
videos are gonna be popping up on screen
one was of this season through awards
from the faction war and the other one
is going to be the fastest way to
Halloween move before the season ends
and before this event ends with that
guys I hope you have a great rest of
your day and peace out